hello and welcome to the cheeky science
show so in this video I'm going to
discuss how to stay mentally grounded
and in particular focusing on during a
PhD CY well as you may or may not know I
am currently doing a PhD and I'm in my
first year and I think that one of the
best ways to learn is from personal
experience from other people and so
given that I have some experience now I
thought it'd be a good topic to talk
about particularly at this time of year
when the weather at least in the UK can
be a little bit grim at times and given
that I've still got quite a way to go
until I finish my PhD so the aim of this
video then would be to discuss some of
the advice that I have for trying to say
what I call mentally grounded and as you
can tell by this current animation of
well what should be a brain on the
ground wearing a PhD cap there'll be
some interesting animations to go along
with these different bits of advice but
this is by no means a full list of
different things that you can do I'm up
to listening to your feedback as well
and different you know different things
about for different people so it's about
finding what works for you and I think
that's the most important thing to take
away from this video so yes I'll talk
about some tips give some advice and try
them for me too discussion where we can
help each other out as well so what do I
actually mean when I say being mentally
grounded
well one definition that I found was
that mentally grounded is when you're
facing reality rather than trying to
believe what you want to believe so what
I mean by this is that you are present
in the moment
and not under any kind of false
pretenses about what's happening in your
work or life because I think in this
current day and age it's so easy to lose
sight of what life is really all about
to have fun and to learn along the way
so my first bit of advice is to don't be
a sheep so what I mean by this is you
need don't always follow the crowd don't
feel that pressure to do something just
because somebody else is doing it and
one good example of this is about how
much time you might be spending at work
you might feel pressure or expect
to get that earlier or to stay there
later than you you feel like you would
want to or need to
and that isn't a problem you know you're
not the same person you're different and
if anything you might just be using your
time more efficiently and speaking of
efficiency I have my own tips for how to
make every moment worthwhile so that you
don't waste time because time is the
most precious thing especially during a
PhD project so how can you be more
efficient then so one really good tip is
to let you plan your day before you go
about it it could be anything from 30
seconds to 2 minutes just jot down what
you need to do that day and then at
least you know you have a plan of what
you've got to get done secondly remove
distractions like our phones are great
but they're also so distracting and I
can't really talk because I'm pretty bad
at putting my phone off like news I
always distracted by it and the last
thing is to get in the flow that's when
we work most efficiently and with free
of distractions and one recent tip I had
to do this was to to pick a song and to
just listen to that song repeats and
repeats and repeats and I tried this the
other day and I actually didn't get sick
up a song surprisingly I don't know how
effective it was actually you know I've
done it I I think is pretty effective if
you choose the right song that is but
anyway going back to my first point just
don't compare yourself to somebody else
you have no idea what's going on with
them as well so just yeah don't compare
yourself and stop so I actually scripted
this video which is something I did
always do I just put meditation I don't
mean I was talking about this one but
meditation it's hard I've tried it and
it's very hard to stick to it but if you
can do it it is actually really
effective because you take just like
five minutes and you get yourself a
chill and in that kind of sense states
in the presence or whatever it's called
and yeah it could work for you I just
found it really hard to commit to you
and so if you're like me and you do find
it challenging the alternative things
that I do is just to sit and think and
appreciates the things that I can do in
my life like the fact that I am
literally alive the fact that I can see
I can smell I can think and how awesome
actually is that that's so awesome
and I think couldn't you have that
realization you do it kind of puts
everything into perspective and so I
definitely recommend doing that at least
once a day once a week it will change
your life literally now my next piece of
advice is being able to turn negatives
into positives so this I think is more
of a skill it takes time to practice it
and to get it to work because it's not
necessarily easy but one example would
be to say something didn't work and you
feel like you just wasted a lot of time
which is definitely negative so how can
you turn that into a positive so if it
means you have to repeat something again
that's a good thing right you know your
practice makes perfect it's being able
and having the opportunity to do
something again just reinforces your
ability to do some it correctly in which
case that could save you more time
downstream that you just don't realize
at that moment another way you can deal
with negatives is through journaling now
I used to watch this youtuber quite a
lot and pretty much every video was at
some point relevant to you how great
journaling is and help an official it
can be used to put your problems down
and to work out solutions and to kind of
get back to what I said before about
gratitude and appreciating what you do
have and yeah this guy was just like
journaling journaling the solution but
there's different types of journaling so
it could be gratitude journaling in
which case you write down the things
that you appreciate but it could also be
goal-setting and just treat it like a
diary as well
just write down what happens to your day
what bits are great what bits once a
great it really is up to you now used to
write a diary when I was a teenager and
I mean I don't anymore but I remember
when I was a teenager I used to love
reading through my previous entries and
so I think any kind of sort of
journaling does seem to have some
benefits so why not give it a try
so my next tip to stay mentally grounded
is to keep your bar green so what do I
mean by this well other kids I used to
play Sims quite a lot and in since every
sim that you were looking after had this
like
NEADS bar something above its height
which basically indicated April
happiness of your Sam and this took into
account lots of different needs of that
sim such as hunger comfort bladder
energy fun social hygiene and
environment and each of these different
bars were fluctuating throughout today
whether or not your sim had eaten lunch
had a good night's sleep had showers and
then you want to do something to be
happy right so you wanted to make sure
that all of these bars were as green as
they could be because that was a happy
sim and you know you looked after your
Sims needs but you've got to look after
your own needs as well so make sure you
keep your imp as green as well it's very
important but more important than this
it's so important during a phd process
that you do look after yourself and make
sure that you do eat well that you do
sleep well and that you also fit in some
exercise as well because that will
maintain your health levels prevent you
from getting ill and will help you to be
mentally grounded so in a similar vein
to maintaining your needs it's also
important to factor in some you time
whereas time that you do something that
you really do enjoy doing or while you
try something new so I guess for me my
you time would be making youtube videos
I suppose but it could be something as
simple as just going for a walk in the
Sun for like thirty minutes at the
weekend it literally makes all the
difference just having some time with
your own thoughts and really evaluating
what it is she wants out of life but um
you don't have to get that deep about it
there are lots of other things that you
can do in your spare time and the point
is is that it should be something
different to your day-to-day work life
so one thing that I think is really good
to do is to just read books like so much
of my undergrad I forgot how amazing it
was to read books so now I make sure
that I fluctuate between reading a
fiction and a nonfiction book because
reading is great like you can learn so
much for them and there's plenty of
places where you can pick up that's
pretty much for free but if reading
isn't your thing there are plenty of
other outside activities that you can
take part in
that really will help you stay mentally
grounded because you literally [ __ ]
in that's activity forget about
everything else that's going on in your
life so this could be something like
taking up a sport or even just going to
the gym to bring a craft activity
learning an instrument or just listening
to music the thing is it doesn't really
matter as long as it distracts you from
the thoughts of course about your work
it has to be something entirely
different so one thing that I like doing
is listening to music and in particular
you should definitely go listen if you
haven't already
it's a Fianna by Billy Joel because the
lyrics I don't know what it is about
them they literally just like sing to me
so here are a few of them that slow down
you crazy child's take the phone off the
hook and disappear for a while the point
is is like you know we get distracted in
this day and age by our phones and by
everyone in our lives we do forget
what's important and the point is it's
all right you can't afford to lose a day
or two you can take some time off to
recharge yourself it's so important to
take those breaks because that is when
the best ideas come and if we're going
to talk about some of my favorite songs
we should also talk about some of my
favorite films which are definitely
Pixar films are up there and one of my
favorite quotes comes from ratatouille
which is the only thing predictable
about life is its unpredictability and I
think this quaint speaks volumes for a
PhD you know you start a project and you
have no idea what that projects going to
go the point is you just have to give
the flow and accept that fate and it's
in line with the crates from dory in
Finding Nemo to just keep swimming and
because I really do love quotes I'll
finish with equate that's featured at
the end of the film Meet the Robinsons
by Walt Disney himself around here
however we don't look backwards for very
long we keep moving forward opening up
needles and doing new things because
we're curious and curiosity keeps
leading us down new paths and so I think
at least in a science PhD this great
really does summarize the main drive for
doing this research is the curiosity is
the interest
it's the intrigue what we can discover
so I hope that some of these tips are at
least useful for you to help stay
mentally grounded and if you have tips
of your own feel free to share them I
think it's important that we look after
each other as well so as always thanks
for listening